[Music]
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you by spectator TV
and broadcast on this Thursday the 12th
of October
2023 my name is Freddy gray I'm the
deputy editor of The Spectator and I
will be your host
today on the show this week we will of
course be covering the biggest news of
the moment which is the war in the
Middle East um that has broken out
following hamas's Terror attacks in the
Holy Land I'll be joined by The
Spectators Douglas Murray and Paul wood
who have both written articles on the
subject in the magazine this week next
up we'll turn to Labor's Party
Conference which happened this week uh
I'll be talking to Stuart Rhoden who was
a conference attendee about uh strange
incident that happened outside the
conference center and the labor party
more
broadly after that we'll be asking if
labor supporters tend to hold luxury
beliefs do you hold luxury beliefs what
are luxury beliefs we'll talk to Matt
Goodwin about a phrase that soel bravman
used in Her speech to Tory Party
Conference last
week and lastly we will talk about
social social media and children is a
social media account more damaging to
Children than a smoking habit I'll be
joined by the center for social justices
Cara Asher Smith and The Spectators very
own Mary Wakefield to talk about this
very very important
subject before we get going I must thank
our sponsors canac cord genuity wealth
management they are brilliant sponsors
and great supporters of this show uh
canac cord are experienced wealth
planners and investment managers who
offer unwavering support in these
challenging times to find out more visit
can do wealth.com
now the big story of the week is of
course the war that is erupting in the
Middle East following the terror attacks
by Hamas on Israel at the weekend I'm
joined Now by Douglas maray uh our
columnist and Paul wood a former BBC
world affairs correspondent and a
frequent
contributor to The Spectator um and uh I
think we'll get into the Middle East
question uh second after with you Paul
after I talked to Douglas a little bit
about his piece in the magazine this
week um the headline of which is uh
Britain must stand up against those who
support Hamas and uh sorry to give away
the ending Douglas but I'm going to do
it um uh you say that you have a
challenge for Rishi sunak well braan Kia
starma and the rest of them uh don't
just say you stand against Terror show
it uh don't just say you stand beside
Israel show it uh the treat these people
by which you mean people in Britain who
Express support for Hamas uh as we did
the supporters of Isis take their
passports strip their citizenship
forcibly remove them from this country
um I think a lot of people are agreeing
with you certainly from the reaction
online there's a lot of anger about what
seemed to be celebration uh celebrations
in London about Terror uh in the Middle
East um however let me put it to you
that it might be trickier than it was
with Isis to uh identify Hamas
supporters because the issue is somewhat
muddled by people who support Palestine
and I don't think you're going to
propose throwing them out of the
country no so if I answer your question
if you have open supporters of terrorist
group and hamaz has been a prescribed
terrorist entity in the UK for some
years now prescribed in its entirety if
you have Sam Hamas supporters in the UK
my suggestion is the UK does not either
want or need them it's also not that
difficult we have senior members of
Hamas living in the UK former members of
the senior military leadership of hamaz
living in the UK this is the UK's shame
it isn't for the British government or
any other government to tell the Israeli
government how they should respond to
the massacre of their civilians but I do
think it's important to just bear in
mind that we can in countries like
Britain or should keep our own house in
order I see no reason why Britain should
have for so many years been a retirement
home for members of the Revolutionary
Islamic government in tan one of whom as
I wrote about in the magazine recently
lives in Harrow I see no reason why
hamas's backers should live in the UK
and I don't see any reason why their
supporters should live in the UK after
Jews have been massacred for being Jews
by hamz in this Isis likee fashion treat
the the people who support that as we
would the supporters of Isis and if you
can't remove their citizenship and expel
them from the UK at least prosecute them
and imprison them under the 26 terrorism
act for the glorification of Terror look
at what happened outside Israeli Embassy
in London the other night crowds of
hundreds of people and again yes there
is a blurry line here because a lot of
people hide behind the idea that they're
supporters of the Palestinian people
when in fact they're just haters of the
Jewish people but look at the people who
turned out the other night before Israel
had done anything in terms of
retaliation against Hamas hundreds and
hundreds of people notably young people
uh who were outside the Israeli Embassy
which had to be boarded up and they were
screaming their hatred of Israel well
what were they doing were they
preemptively opposing an Israeli
backlash no of course not not they were
rejoicing in the massacre of Israeli
citizens and as I say in the peace this
is erupted all across Britain we have
people in Brighton talking about how
beautiful the massacre of Jews is in
Israel and being applauded by crowds we
see in other countries other democracies
the same the same way in which people
have used our system and taken rights
they would never give us in return what
about the people in Sydney outside the
Sydney Opera House again after the
massacres before any retaliation
chanting gas the Jews in Sydney Israel
has its problems but we in the western
democracies have ours and our main one
is that we have people in our countries
who celebrate Terror and I say get them
all out well I I I I understand entirely
what you're saying and I agree with it
to a large extent but I just think there
may be a difficult to sort of carry on
in this muddling point there may be
different laws that would need to be
used here um one would obviously be
Terror legislation and Hamas is a
terrorist prescribed terrorist group um
but the other thing we have to use would
be hate laws uh and I think there you
get into difficult territory well hate
laws are all weak I don't an things I
don't particular you believe in hate
laws I think hate laws are a sort of
watery thing that that lacks and um sup
governments imposed because they
couldn't just impose the rule of law as
it existed um so I'm not very interested
in in hate laws I am interested in the
glorification of Terror and the and the
and the proposition that people should
be allowed to support terrorism in your
country let me put it this way um on the
let's take something like an extremely
rare but awful thing like for instance
the Christ Church mosque Massacre some
years ago in New Zealand imagine if
after that Massacre um there had been a
protest outside the embassies of new New
Zealand around the world of people
celebrating the Lone Wolf gunman who
went and shot shot up that mosque would
we be see saying well they're just
expressing a sort of you know h a right
to free expression um or or maybe
they're objecting to the New Zealand
government's potential to have a
backlash against no we would say quite
rightly well these people are obviously
glorifying the terrorist we all know
that it would happen if it was that way
round we all know that so why is it the
Jewish people have to be the one people
in the world who are expected to be
massacred and to have to respond with
Equanimity towards that and when they're
taunted on the Streets of London and
other Capital Cities across Europe are
meant to just sit back back and accept
it we didn't take that view with Isis we
didn't take it with Al-Qaeda we
shouldn't take it with
Hamas uh another uh debate that sort of
springing up uh on the domestic reaction
here in Britain uh is this issue of
projecting uh Israeli Flags onto British
government buildings or or flying
Israeli flags from British government
public buildings I wonder how you feel
about that I knowe that the uh Muslim
Council of uh mosques in London has
written to the government um expressing
its horror at that which I suppose is
only to be expected but I think a lot of
people feel and perhaps they're right
that uh public buildings shouldn't be
used for the flying of any flag other
than the British flag oh well here's the
thing though isn't it after the after
the B Clan massacres in France it was
almost the regar for people to say uh to
to fly uh French flags and thank
goodness we did an attempt to show a
weak attempt but an attempt to show
solidarity um in fact when when other
attacks have happened against across
Western democracies it's become a sort
of Norm to do that you may like that or
you may not but here's the thing why why
should it be the case that I mean again
hardly surpris uring when we're talking
about the MCB but why should it be the
case sort of lower down the food chain
as it were that people would say yes of
course we must show solidarity if it's
if it's the French who are massacred by
islamist barbarians but if it's the
Israelis who are massacred by islamist
barbarians who's to say whether we
should fly the flag of the country
that's suffered I I think if you've set
the precedent of trying to show
unanimity and solidarity with friends
been massacred by Barbarians in one
country you should probably do it with
the others as well but there always an
Israeli exception and Israeli exception
is that people endlessly think oh maybe
it's going to be divisive it's only
divisive in the UK because we've let in
an awful lot of people who support
terrorism when it's done by the
terrorists of groups like Hamas against
the Jewish Nation so so no I mean I
think that anyone who who sort of has a
sudden problem with that now should have
had it had a bigger problem with it
earlier on and I think if they have a
problem with it now when it comes to the
flag of Israel it tells us doesn't much
more about themselves than it does about
Israel yes well let's let's move on to
uh the question of what's all the
questions about what's going on um in
Israel and and The Holy Land um Paul
I'll come to you you've got a excellent
typically excellent piece in this week's
magazine uh in which you speak to
various people who do know a lot about
this uh and the big questions everyone
everyone started asking as soon as this
happened was the involvement of Iran the
extent of Iranian involvement can you
tell us a little bit about what you were
able to
discover we should say first of all
there's no proof of Iranian involvement
and in fact the US uh the White House in
the US says that American intelligence
agencies are looking for that proof but
haven't found it so what you have is
well-founded supposition and the
well-founded supposition says that Hamas
already gets a lot of money from Iran
maybe $100 million a year is well known
to have received technical support from
Iran on how to build bombs from everyday
materials like pipes and fertilizer and
sugar and also there have been a lot of
meetings between senior Hass figures and
Senior figures from the Iranian KS Force
which directs Iranian foreign policy so
Joe Raburn who used to run Iran policy
on the US National Security Council
who's quite a legendary figure in the
Middle East to people who follow these
events says that to his mind there's
absolutely no doubt that Iran was behind
this because the could force when it has
a client like Hamas
almost without exception uh directs that
client uh for any major initiative uh
tells that client like Hamas how it will
be done when it will be done and in
rayburn's view this was done for Iranian
strategic reion reasons uh not Hamas
strategic reasons and those reasons
would be that Iran doesn't yet have a
nuclear weapon uh needs to uh
Israel and by extension the US needs to
support Hezbollah its militia in Lebanon
to the north and and therefore wants to
tie Israel down using Hamas and rather
worryingly his view is that uh this also
means that the Iranians will activate
Hezbollah to attack Israel if it looks
like Hamas will be destroyed and
therefore Hezbollah will be isolated
that for Iran is a strategic imperative
all of that does make perfect sense but
there is as yet no proof of
it um another interesting point that
comes out of your piece uh is uh one
Hamas figure uh suggesting uh almost
sort of accidentally suggesting but
suggesting that uh the attack was not
entirely in their control uh can you
explain a little bit more about
that this is assama hamdan who's a very
senior member of Hamas a member of their
polit Bureau who I must say seemed
almost taken aback by what had happened
and scrambling to catch up and you can
imagine that this was something kept
very close to the military wing of Hamas
in its planning and then spokesman and
politicians like him have to run to
catch up and just justify it I get a
stream of Hamas press releases on my
phone the latest of which says that
there were no atrocities this is the
Western media making things up this is
the Israelis making things up these of
course are absurd lies there was mass
murder um it's been well documented and
yet Hamas seeks to deny it um in his
view this was a military operation
against military targets and as he told
me the Israelis are playing up the
civilian casualties because they are
embarrassed about the extent to which
which there was a total collapse of
their army around Gaza and there was in
fact a collapse it was 12 hours 24 hours
before um some of the Israeli towns
kutes that were under attack uh got help
from the Army um he's pointed out um
some videos such as a Hamas fighter
apparently asking permission to take
food from an Israeli house a Hamas
fighter apparently telling a woman and
her two children we are Muslim we will
not hurt you again the uh the Hamas
media machine is pushing out those
videos this
morning um but ultimately and this is
the justic justification you get from
from people I've been phoning all around
the region um we've been killed uh
there's a double standard here
Palestinians have been constantly killed
and when we hit back uh everybody
sympathizes with Israel what about the
Palestinian Dead uh he also said
something very interesting um about uh
Hamas being forced into doing this
because of the rapid pace of settlement
in the West Bank which in his view made
the possibility um of a Palestinian
State too remote ever to be achievable
and he almost felt this was the last
chance to do something about that now to
those who who disbelieve that particular
argument I also had a very similar
argument from a former head of mosad the
Israeli spy agency Danny atom who said
look Netanyahu had a mellian policy of
cynically building up Hamas in order to
weaken the PLO which is the main
interlocutor with Israel there are no
talks with Hamas there are talks with
the PLO Netanyahu wanted to the
possibility of a Palestinian State and
gambled and made a terrible mistake in
building up Hamas in order to do
that Dr so I wondered you ask you about
uh Israel making terrible mistakes uh I
mean you put in your piece uh the
Israelis will respond as they see fit it
isn't for non- Israelis to give them
advice uh and I I see that point um but
also if we feel Israel our Ally maybe
making a great mistake uh in its
response may even be falling into a trap
possibly even a Iranian set trap uh is
there not some uh validity to the
argument that by uh reacting as
violently as as they seem to be reacting
uh they are only uh you know people talk
about mowing the the grass in in Gaza um
they're only creating the conditions for
it to for it to grow back even more ugly
well first of all I don't agree with the
proposition that Israel has done
anything significant or anything
significantly bloody to date and I can
certainly say with absolute
certainty uh that no Israeli soldier has
yet gone in and mass gang raped and then
uh stabbed and beheaded uh women in the
Gaza we're not dealing with the endless
issue of it's a particularly British
fetish this it's weird a fetish about
proportionality in Conflict if there was
proportionality in Conflict then it
would see that we would have to allow
the Israelis to go and gang rape and
behead uh the same number of women and
children as the f as the so-called
Fighters and militants the terrorists of
Hamas did in Israel so Israel hasn't
responded with 1% of the barbarism that
was shown on Israeli territory last
Saturday not a bit of it what Israel
does have to do is to reassert its own
um impenetrability
its own um
impermeability and that is what one of
the many things that suffered such a
blow at the weekend the the uh belief
that Israeli intelligence is all knowing
took a huge hit the idea that the IDF is
endlessly able to defend the Israeli
people against all enemies took a
massive hit the idea that Tech uh can
can stand in for human beings at border
crossings and so on took a huge hit the
tech technological prowess and much more
has taken a huge hit so the most
important thing I should think that
Israel would need to do is to is to
build those uh things even if they are
myths back up uh and it should be
allowed to do so uh that might well
include doing things which uh um people
sitting comfortably in other Western
democracies think they oughtn't to do
but I would have thought that if and
again by proportion of
population if some tens of thousands of
British people were massacred at the
weekend at a music festival and house to
house in small towns uh in a part of our
country I think we would be quite tired
of people who said they were friends
saying to us now don't overreact chaps
will you don't do anything bad hold it I
mean there's something so insulting
about the way in which people think as I
said earlier that the the the the one
Jewish nation in the world is the one
nation that is expected to just suck
suck suck such things up William hay did
it in the times the other day don't fall
for this trap chaps um well there are
lots of things that Israel could do uh
and uh I I will it'll be very
interesting in the weeks ahead whether
people remember the initial atrocities
that will have cause the war to come and
keep them in mind or whether those same
people end up being the people who par
particular in Britain always end up
saying oh proportionality we showed no
proportionality in conflicts we've had
in the UK in the past and when whenever
Britain has been attacked what do you
think it meant in the second world war
when people sent home postcards saying
we didn't take many prisoners
today so no the endless urging of
restraint on Israel is an endless urging
that the International Community does
because Israel is the only country in
the world never allowed to win a war
War that's why by the way you have the
situation in the Gaza you have all the
international idiots telling the
Israelis they have to withdraw and then
what happens you give the Palestinians a
statelet and they they give you Hamas
and War uh anyone who thinks the West
Bank is going to be a Palestinian state
is now living with the fairies and it's
not because of the Israelis it's because
the Palestinian Authority hasn't wished
to create a state for decades it never
did it's only ever been interested in
creating a state from The River To The
Sea as they always say it's never been
interested in a two-state solution
Palestinian Authority under two leaders
now has repeatedly turned down every
Israeli offer uh of of peace they
offered 99% of what they wanted just 15
years ago they turned it down again as
aasa Arafat did at Oslo they don't want
a two-state solution they want a
one-state solution and that's a Jewish
cleared Palestinian State Paul I wonder
what you make of Douglas's point there I
think the two-state solution is probably
dead which is a Pity because it's the
only solution which makes sense in the
long run um Israel I think has begun
intense bombing already and will have to
go in on the ground having destroyed the
obvious targets Hamas is this amalgam of
both a states with government buildings
to bomb and a Guerilla force and the
guerillas have now withdrawn into the
civilian
population uh which is being hit by
Israel now what Hamas did um was a war
crime um murder were committed this is
against international law but Israel is
a state which at least pretends to be
governed by international law and know
one of the suggestions which came out in
the in the horrible 24 hours of chaos
and
confusion um when this happened at the
weekend was a former Israeli General
called guor Island who was the southern
Commander used to be in charge of Gaza
saying that what we should do is go in
and literally poison the wells
97% of gaza's water comes from these
saltwater Wells has to be purified in
water purification plants um gor Island
general Island wanted to um destroy
those purification plants saying
everybody will say we're deliberately
causing a humanitarian disaster and we
will be doing that as a means to get our
hostages back and Destroy Hamas well
that would almost certainly be a breach
of international law it would be
Collective punishment and this perhaps
is the kind of trap which Hamas whether
knowingly or unknowingly because Iran
push them to do this has set for Israel
a lot of Israelis strategists and people
who thought about this don't want a
reoccupation of the Gaza Strip they know
that that way lies more misery and more
Bloodshed and by the way in the end
Israel is going to have to talk to Hamas
and pro probably is talking to them
already through intermediaries about the
hostages talking through Kata um there
is the outlines of a settlement there
it's still the two-state solution
impossible as that seems now it's even
one which so-called moderates in Hamas
this is an organization with moderates
and hardliners like any other it's a
solution that some in Hamas do want
eventually despite the atrocities at the
weekend I I think I'm sry disagree with
Paul but greatly respect but I think I I
think it's it's it's nonsense to let
think there's any such thing as a
two-state solution on the table I don't
think it has been I think that it's been
the sort of thing that uh a certain type
of Western politician who who hasn't
been following it very closely thinks
always is a Perpetual answer the truth
is is that nobody wants the Palestinian
people the Arabs Nations don't want them
if the jordanians cared about the
Palestinian peoples they would have
taken them in uh 50 years ago if the
Egyptians cared about the Palestinian
peoples they' have taken them in from
the Gaza many years ago the Egyptians
don't like them the jordanians don't
want them none of the other countries in
the region want them but it's very
convenient for them to all make the
Palestinians Israel's problem I see no
reason why the Palestinian peoples have
to be Israel's problem uh as I say the
Israeli uh people have learned a very
unpleasant lesson in the last 17 years
now that if you give the Palestinians
territory they will give you rock in
return and you can always find people uh
like General you just cited in the
immediate aftermath of unspeakable
atrocities of a Kind not seen since
World War II you can always find
somebody who who who who will voice a
particular vengeful opinion but that's
because there's Vengeance in the air
because an atrocity was committed and
again if this had been done against the
British public if this had been an
attack on Britain I'd have thought we'd
find a lot of vengeful people here at
least I'd hope so I I think that's quite
right Doug I take that point but I
suppose the difference is uh Britain
isn't Israel uh and we are not
surrounded by countries that wish to um
annihilate us uh and so therefore
Israel's response uh you know a Wise
Wise Council might be uh not to respond
uh in in the retaliatory way that a lot
of Israeli politicians are now not to
respond all I mean for instance why
should Kata be be be hosting the heads
of Hamas why should Kata not be held
responsible uh one reason I'll tell you
right away is that kataar has managed to
buy up a whole load of influence in
countries like this one nobody will talk
about that what should happen which is
among other things retaliatory strikes
against Hamas leaders who live in Kata
but of course Britain won't do that
because Britain's been
compromised like so many countries so I
mean a lot of British politicians and
others will say oh Don't Do Anything
That Rocks the boat Israel and among
other things what they mean is we've
lost control of things including our
parts of our financial system we can't
control the British streets so don't you
in Israel do anything that makes a mess
of our streets well again that's not
Israel's problem that's ours it's us
who've been the idiots Paul uh Douglas
says and nobody really wants a
Palestinian state do you think the
European Union wants a Palestinian State
it's thrown uh billions in support uh to
Palestine uh probably I I mean this is
in one sense Douglas is right there is
no two-state solution for the
foreseeable future but in another sense
it's the only game in town and uh for
instance Danny at Tom the former mosad
Chief said that with 500,000 settlers
now in the West Bank and more being
pushed in by the Netanyahu government
that was an attempt to make the
two-states solution impossible no doubt
the Palestinians um or the PLO as
indirect Israel's main negotiating
partner carries a lot of blame for that
too but in yon's view um this was uh
Netanyahu carrying out a long-standing
policy of some Israeli governments to
try to Annex the West Bank and the
response from Hamas um the bloody
massacre that we saw last weekend in the
words of the Hamas spokesman um who
talked to me about it was they felt they
they were being backed into a corner um
that's their
calculation um it's the innocent people
who who suffer in this um Palestinian
children bleed too on the first day of
Israel's bombing um a family of 19 who'
fled their home because of a warning
shot nearby to another building were in
the building when it was hit by a
missile 19 people dead mostly women and
children um according to the AP reporter
on the scene didn't seem to be a
military Target there of course this is
what happens when Guerilla armies which
is what Hamas is retrea to the civilian
population of course this is what
happens in the builtup slums that
constitute most of G a city uh it may
not be um the aim of Israeli policy
although most in the Arab world will
certainly think that it is one of the
dispiriting things in the 24 or 48 hours
after the attack was looking at the Arab
press and seeing almost no coverage of
the Israeli victims people's hearts were
hardened right from the outset and
that's what I got in telephone calls
with people they feel they have their
victims that have always been ignored
and now they're ignoring the Jewish
victims makes you very pessimistic about
any outcome one thing we can say with
absolute certainty is uh that the
soldiers of Israel are not going to be
hiding among civilian populations and
using the populations as Shields that is
exactly what hamaz has done it's exactly
what the fight the fighter terrorists of
Hamas have done it's their plan so you
know there's also an issue not only of
proportionality but of intentionality
and the intention of Hamas last week was
to kill as many innocent people as
possible the intention of Israel very
clearly as has been shown in many
engagements is to kill as few innocent
people as possible that difference might
seem academic to some people but in it
lies everything there's a lot more to
talk about uh but sadly we don't have
time um so uh Douglas and Paul for now
thank you very much for joining
spectator
TV now the horrifying events of the
Middle East overshadowed the labor Party
Conference somewhat this week in
Liverpool however there was a related
incident um that occurred
outside the conference center uh where
some Pro Palestinian activists were
confronted by a Jewish man who was
rather upset at what they were saying
that man was Stuart Rhoden who joins us
now uh first of all St let's look at the
clip under St is bad under Jeremy
[Music]
cor attack me attack me like you attack
them coward dis
you came into a country you murdered
children this is not the time to be
doing this not in the
aftermath what happened 24 hours ago
You' been ashamed of yourself you can
step back let this it's disgusting are
you going to murder individuals are you
going to murder individuals like you did
over the weekend Stuart Stuart rhen has
very kindly joined us down the line um
Stuart tell us a little bit about what
happened uh outside Labour Party
Conference
there of course so I I I I went to the
conference to to hear um Rachel rea's
speech I had to leave early um and I
have to say the M the mood there was
slightly subdued because of um events in
Israel for sure and then I come across
this demonstration probably I know 120
people with Palestinian flags and
messages and there was a a community
officer standing there and I I said to
him am I able am I permitted to have my
own counter rally and demonstration and
he said absolutely why not I said
fantastic so uh that's exactly what I
did and of course um I had to raise my
voice because it was you know what one
against 100
120 and um it was very instinctive
obviously not planned I didn't know it
would be there when I when I walked out
and the guttural fear I had uh was that
this is an incredibly disrespectful uh
insensitive and insulting thing to be
doing at best they started coming up to
me and I saw some of their signs I
realized that actually um what they
were uh saying and what they were
shouting was actually kind of worse than
that uh and um to do that in the
aftermath um of what had happened over
the weekend kind of the massacre The
Butchery the the terror that was spread
uh of which we're finding out obviously
more now than we even knew then uh was
was totally inappropriate and I didn't
want to stand by and do nothing I didn't
want to walk past without having said
something so that's that's that's what
happened the video's obviously been seen
quite a lot it's been quite a story um I
was wondering if you've had any follow
up have you had any further
abuse uh none absolutely none and what
is incredibly heartening is to get
messages from people I don't know uh
from friends of friends from people of
different parts uh of the world um and
many many not only were they supported
but they said had they been there they
would have stood next to me so I've had
absolutely uh no abuse at all Ju Ju Just
support I know you're Keen not to get
dragged into uh a big discussion about
Labor and anti-Semitism but it's hard to
talk about this without touching on on
the matter um obviously the labor party
of Jeremy Corbin uh was quite different
or positioned itself very differently to
K starm on this issue K starm and other
labor leaders were quite clear in their
condemnation of um a masses
attacks uh I was just wondering if you
know your relationship with the labor
party has changed as a result of that
change yeah 100% 100% and there was
absolutely no way I would um and I voted
for different parties over my life
there's absolutely no way I would have
voted for Jeremy Corbin and didn't and
voted actively against him and um I
think um K has done an incredibly good
job on that and it's
absolutely clear in my mind that those
people um who were
demonstrating would have been inside the
hall under the previous regime um and
clearly they're now not allowed they've
been expelled from the
party and
[Music]
um the the idea um that the party hasn't
changed is is is ludicrous because it
seriously seriously has and I think uh
as I say witness those people outside
not inside and also of course uh people
like Luciana Burger who was um left the
party and rejoined earlier this year or
other very clear signs of a complete
change on this um we've seen various
protest
uh all over the world really all over
the developed world uh for Palestine and
against Israel and often with quite an
explicitly anti-jewish
message I think we saw people singing
Gas the Jews in Sydney uh we've seen
people firing fireworks at the uh
Israeli Embassy in London um I wonder if
you tell us a little bit about how that
makes you feel whether whether you know
was that was it was it your awareness
that that that was going to be the
reaction that led you to to re react to
the way you did um against those labor
protesters uh the answer is no as I said
it was it was an instinctive reaction uh
but but I think there's absolutely no
doubt Hamas go for Palestinian uh the
lives of Palestinian children um and and
women and the weak uh they would have
known the response would have been
strong and it is just not something that
comes into their calculous and I'm
afraid we
are in in another Clash of civilizations
one that respects life
uh and everything that it stands for and
I tell you that Israel even if it does
have an aggressive response which it
needs to have to protect its borders
which is the first priority of every
government it will do everything in its
power as it always has done to avoid
civilian casualties that is not the same
of the other side in the Jewish
Community clearly there's been a lot of
grief and shock because we all have
friends and family who live in Israel or
know people who do so it's it's all very
very connected and of of course we saw
the um vandalism of a shop uh kosher
shop on Sunday morning we saw have seen
offensive graffiti we've seen Flags
taken down and there is fear there is
real fear um you would have read that a
a Jewish secondary school has told its
kids not to wear its Blazers for fear of
attack it's stopped detention so kids
don't go home late and people are scared
and we shouldn't be scared uh living
living in this country and uh I thank
you know the police for uh being there
looking after us they are protecting us
for sure I hope matters don't escalate
but where we see and this is something
which I I will say I didn't recognize
when I did that demonstration but when
you say see things that say free free
Palestine that only means one thing and
it's absolutely fine for people to be
critical of Israeli policies that's fine
but demonization of Israel is modern day
anti-Semitism it used to be religious
anti-Semitism it was them racial um
today anti-Semitism is defined by
demonization and Del deionization of
Israel and that's what some of those
people were saying and singing and
that's what some of their posters say
and I really do hope and I've seen what
the current home secretary said about
this that she said she'll be tough on
that to me that is incitement to hatred
waving a flag uh I think is going to be
nuanced and people don't have to make
their own decisions about it but it's
interesting that the uh Israeli uh sorry
the Palestinian ambassador to this
country hasn't condemned the Hamas
attacks and I guess this is going to
become quite a big issue but we can't
have Jewish people walking around the
streets in fear of their own safety in
life and in fact when I left the
demonstration on Monday morning I was
going to walk back to the station and
the two police officers said they wanted
to escort me so I got escort complete
waste of resource I I I thanked them for
it and I had two plain closed people a
policeman escorting me I'm sure this
would not have happened the other way
around there's no way if it was the
other way around where it had been the
Jewish demonstration and of course the
Jewish Community would never ever ever
have held a demonstration if there was
ever a situation where there had been
cold bladed Massacre committed by
Israelis or Jewish people it it just
wouldn't happen so I hope we we will be
safe I I appreciate everything that the
um the government and the police are
doing are doing for us uh but I think
these are going to be some pretty tricky
times ahead and what I would say um and
I've heard this from lots of young
people um who are either at school or
University or the workplace or amongst
their friends if you are uh thinking
about what you should say to someone who
is Jewish or Israeli or you know is very
committed uh to to these these issues
it's a bit like when someone dies don't
cross the road put your arm around them
send them a message say something
because it it goes a long long way it
really goes a long way to know that
we're not alone and there are other
people in this country and AAR who care
for us and are grieving with us for the
loss that we've just had David bedil uh
the comedian uh says that anti-Semitism
is is the the last acceptable hatred in
Britain or the only acceptable hatred in
Britain do you would you go that far I I
I know what he's saying uh I agree with
his General thrust it's a long long
discussion but what I do know is that at
times like this we have faced proper
anti-Semitism and anti-Semitism which
can often be violent so this is not you
know casual um and I'm afraid it's
organized you saw that as you said what
happened outside the Israeli Embassy and
people are yeah we've read it people
went to there to kind uh show their
support for Israel and they were
basically turned back because of the
hostile environment in which they faced
the David's point is a you know a Nuance
one and a deeper one and you know I have
a lot of sympathy for it but but today
the issue is is our is our safety and
we've seen these things escalate I think
the number of year on year when they
looked at the same dates last year the
number of anti-Semitic instances are a
threefold in three or four days and I'm
afraid uh that that that will continue
um and this you know remember this is
these started these started before there
had been in response given you know the
catastrophe that happened in Israel but
this was when they had seen what the
Carnage was they were doing that
celebration so clearly we're now Israel
is going to defend its its bers it's
going to defend its people which is the
first priority of any democratically
elected government and unfortunately
there is going to be you know collateral
damage which we we we are sorry about we
are truly sorry we don't want that and
so yes I do I do have fears that that
this could escalate in this country too
as it is around the world well Stuart
with uh Brave voices such as your own uh
I'm sure there'll be fierce resistance
to that thank you very much for coming
on to spectator TV pleasure thank
you now one of the more remarkable
speeches at last week's Tory Party
Conference was made uh by the Home
Secretary s bravman in which she talked
about luxury beliefs uh which is a
phrasee I believe coined by Rob
Henderson the uh American academic um
but it's also something that our next
guest Matt Goodwin um talks about Matt
has a new book called values voice and
virtue uh and Matt you've written quite
a lot about this subject uh can you
define for us first of all for anyone
who hasn't um heard the term before what
luxury beliefs are and why they
represent an opportunity for the Tory
party
yeah sure uh luxury beliefs really refer
to ideas or views which confer status on
members of the elite which bring members
of the elite few costs but which impose
very heavy cost on other people so an
example of a luxury belief might be uh
members of the political media cultural
class calling for large scale
immigration because they're the least
likely to suffer the negative effects of
that but we know from research
workingclass non-graduate voters are the
most likely to suffer the effects of
that or similarly calling for a more
relaxed approach to family whereas we
know members of the the elite are the
most likely to get married stay married
and have children within marriage it's
everybody else that suffers from the
collapse of of those guard rails so
luxury belief is luxury beliefs are
really about the sort of hypocrisy that
lie at the the heart of uh some people
in the elite and for the conservative
party when it comes to issues like
migration diversity identity family
crime uh some prominent uh uh
politicians SW bravman included clearly
think that there's some political
Capital to be had by zooming in on some
of those
contradictions do you think perhaps
there isn't as much political Capital as
perhaps soel brodman thinks because
we've just had the labor party
conference and
uh I think it's quite clear that K
starmer is is playing down that sort of
politics uh he's trying not to talk even
if these issues are Salient he's not
talking about them or he's dismissing
them as populism without getting too
stuck in
them I I think there's another view
which is you know labor are playing a
very risky game when it comes to these
these issues because you know look since
the the brexit referendum we were often
told that that voters don't really care
about these these issues around
immigration and identity anymore well we
know that that's not true we know that
for example migration both legal and
illegal is back to being the third most
important issue for all voters and the
most important issue for those 2019
conservative voters who only last week
rated it above the economy which is
really quite remarkable when you
consider we're in the most severe cost
of living crisis for half a century and
even still many of those voters who of
course left labor for Boris Johnson are
saying that for them immigration is is
still a Paramount issue so for labor and
Karma to
downplay that issue to essentially not
talk about it during the labor
conference there's a little bit of
discussion about you know smashing the
gangs but there wasn't really a sort of
serious discussion about either how to
bring down legal migration or how to
actually um prevent illegal migration
over the longer term um I would argue
that's a very risky political strategy
for labor and leaves the conservatives
you know with a big opening if they can
if they can find a way to to kick a
football into
it um and what about I mean obviously
migration is a huge one and as you point
out there is there is some Capital there
for the Tories politically um but on
other issues do you think it's fair to
say that the the slur of populism is
more uh effective that it is perhaps in
America because we often hear it said
and it's it's not just an elite opinion
we of here said that Brits Brits don't
particularly like these issues coming
into politics they don't like you know
woke issues they don't like
transgenderism as a political subject it
turns them off uh in both directions
left and
right I you know I don't find that
particularly convincing I mean if you
look at the issues that we often refer
to as as quote unquote culture wars
these issues are often actually very
Central to the way in which people think
about their lives so immigration is a
great example about 75% of people would
like to lower overall migration they
think it's been too high over the last
decade uh they think it's been badly
managed if you look for example at
gender issues well in Scotland when
people began to look at the gender
recognition Reform Bill they became
really interested in it and of course
80% said this is a terrible idea if you
look at issues like crime uh the British
public are consistently more Hardline
than both uh labor and conservative
politicians and you look at issues like
political correctness or or you know
woke ideology um you know that again is
is something that concerns about 60% of
Brits who say they feel in today's
climate they can't really say what they
want to to say so I I don't buy the
argument the uh you know so-called
culture wars which by the way you know
these issues are often foundational to
to who we are the rights of family the
rights of women sex-based rights history
identity you know this is all pretty
Central stuff I I I don't think you can
just push this out of politics I think
this is now in the center of politics
and in the Public Square and so that's
why we saw Rishi sunak in Manchester
make explicit reference to these issues
in his speech now a Critic would say he
was also rather vague about what he
wanted to do you know he said a woman is
a woman a man is a man well does that
mean the conservatives are going to do
what the Republicans have done in terms
of intervening in schools and
universities and you know soel braan
what she said and I've pulled is very
popular in the country 66% of all Brits
think that mass immigration is an
existential challenge to the west but
what are the actual policies that the
conservatives are going to introduce are
they going to reduce legal migration are
they going to increase the salary
thresholds that are currently allowing I
would argue um too much low School
migration are they going to clamp down
on International students and their
dependence in a more long-term
sustainable way you know these are all
things that we don't really have the
answers to so it's difficult for the
conservatives to outflank labor
on migration because they they haven't
really gone all in when it comes to
delivering a policy that would act
actually meet uh a majority of British
voters where they are so it makes it
very difficult for the conservatives
there is an opportunity but they have to
bring the policies forward to seiz it
you're quite CTI about the term culture
wars there and I and I get what you mean
but isn't that precisely what you're
getting out there that for a lot of
Voters uh if it's just talk if it's just
uh headlines and odd statement um by the
Tories about stopping the boats or uh
Pro family or whatever um if if there
aren't any serious pro- family policies
put in place um then voters don't really
care either way what either part is
saying voters are very disillusioned
across the board I recently pulled um uh
a big nationally representative sample
of Voters and I asked them what are the
issues that you feel really concerned
about but also feel you're not
represented on number one was IM
migration most people want it lowered
most people want it slowed down neither
of the parties are committed to that
number two was political correctness
people feeling like they cannot say what
they think neither party is seriously
committed to rooting out uh this sort of
stifling um you know Progressive
ideology so-called Progressive ideology
in the institutions which has left so
many people feeling as though they can't
really say what they they want want want
to say and the third was promoting
Britain's distinctive
identity history and culture against
what many people feel as a sort of bland
globalization Universal liberal ideology
that sort of celebrates diversity but
isn't really all that interested in the
distinctive things about Britain the
things that make us British or English
or Welsh or Scottish and and those are
the things that people really do feel
animated about and all politics is about
supply and demand and I think in Britain
what we've got at the moment is actually
lots of public demand for a different
kind of politics but we don't have much
Supply we don't have either labor or the
conservative party really meeting voters
on those on those issues and so this big
consensus that we have a kind of big
State uh High tax uh kind of uh low
productivity High
immigration um you know London Centric
economy still is alienating a lot of
Voters they do want to talk about these
issues they do want to talk about what
their kids are being taught around sex
gender and race they do want to talk
about the constant revision of British
history they do care about these things
about their shared identity they also
care about the cost of living they also
care about housing but I simply don't
buy the argument that these are Fringe
issues which politicians shouldn't talk
about because if you want to see one
politician and you know this much better
than me Fred if you want to see one
politician who's Riding High in the poll
still and who's talking a lot about this
where you look at America and you can
see with the Republicans and the current
polling that they are still actually
holding together the post 2016
realignment if you look at how strongly
supportive workingclass voters are of um
Donald Trump non-graduates pensioners uh
small Towners Suburban women all the
groups by the way that the British
Tories have managed to alienate and lose
over the last uh few years certainly
since 2019 the Republicans are actually
in play I mean they've still got that
realignment and irrespective of how you
feel about Donald Trump as a as a case
study of how to hold together a
coalition and by the way they've also
eaten into Hispanic Latino voters in a
significant way you know they've done
that partly by leaning into many of
these cultural questions by actually
recognizing that voters want to have a
conversation about the things that make
them who they who they are their history
their identity their culture what we
teach our children uh now whether the
British Tories decide to step into that
not not necessarily saying they should
become a trumpian party but if they
become a more interventionist party on
these issues a more culturally
conservative party that's willing to
actually have a conversation with the
country about these issues then I
suspect they will have a lot more room
for maneuver um in at the elections to
come I suppose it's quite a difficult
thing to prove uh but it seems to me
from a from an observational point of
view that uh the more popular these
issues become with the public the more
uh the progressive ruling class uh who
hold these luxury opinions um Harden in
their views and I think we see that
within the conservative party of it's
not that the conservatives disagree
necessarily it's just that they
associate it with a sort of politics
they find ugly and probably in a
snobbish sense because this is to a
large extent a class
division yeah well I think that's spot
on I think if you you know why is it
that the British Tories unlike
conservatives in Italy Sweden France and
America have actually been very
reluctant to get involved it doesn't
take you long in the Tory movement to
find somebody who's critical of soel
bran I mean what she's come out and said
has actually been quite unpopular around
the cabinet table why is that because
their status conscious Tories I mean
they are they view cultural issues as
being beneath them uh they view issues
around migration and and integration and
sex and gender and history and statues
you know all this stuff is kind of you
know low brow it's not status-driven
politics and that's where they're
missing a trick I mean that's where they
are
really struggling and if you look at the
2019 electorate that rallied around
Boris Johnson you know wanting lower
migration stronger borders tough
approach on crime promoting Britain's
distinctive identity in history which
you know we've seen over the last three
and four years be consistently eroded by
the advance of radical
progressivism uh the conservatives are
only holding about 60% of that vote now
so you know that 40% has basically left
the party a big chunk gone to labor a
big chunk gone to form um but a bigger
chunk has said you know I'm not going to
vote at the next election I'm completely
disillusioned and so what I often say to
Cabinet ministers and I said to one last
week is you know we are now in a world
where voters basically want security
they and they don't just want Economic
Security from the cost of living crisis
from the uh from the declining living
standards they don't just want physical
security from a collapsing National
Health Service they don't just want um
National Security from small boats from
rising immigration from culturally
different groups who we've seen this
week protesting and supporting the
atrocities in in Israel on the Streets
of London they also want cultural
security they want a cultural security
from this oppressive stifling Orthodoxy
which has left them feeling as though
well if they don't agree with radical
progressives on on pro-immigration PR
globalization pro-social liberalism
they're going to be outcast you know
they might lose their jobs or they might
be silent
and I think this cultural security
notion is one that's going to become
increasingly Central to our politics
especially given the fact that 85 to 90%
of Voters in Britain really do feel very
strongly attached to Britain they feel
proud of the country they um they view
their national identity as a key part of
who they are that's not like the people
who dominate many of the institutions
they it's not to say they don't like
Britain but they don't attach as much
importance to their national identity so
Rift is going to become still I think
much more Central to our politics as we
navigate the 2020s and Beyond and lastly
Matt uh just as a matter of curiosity
have you in all of your polling picked
up a strong desire uh in among the
British public to ban smoking for young
people um not consistently I mean I've
not pulled it um extensively myself and
I've not not focus grouped here but if
you look at some of the polling that we
have had since the ban um yugov uh I
think I'm right in saying F that a
plurality of supportive of the ban um a
minority oppose it um but I've not done
any uh detailed work on it but probably
fair to say it's not a priority for
British vors oh it's it's no it's not a
priority at all and actually one of the
things I wrote about in uh on on my
substat was about um you know sunx
speech was bizarre for that reason which
is if you look at the top three issues
for all voters in country number one is
cost of living number two is NHS and
number three is migration and migration
is both legal and illegal um and the
problem is you know he decided to focus
on the smoking ban a levels and a train
line into Northern England and these are
just not Salient issues for the country
and I wonder why he went so far off the
grid in his conference speech and when
you compare and contrast that to K Aras
I have to say even though
played down immigration which I
mentioned was risky he did at least talk
a lot about the salian issues about the
cost of living crisis about the state of
the NHS about housing about some of
these really big tanic issues and I
think sunak you know I understand the
strategy of being more competitive but
he's got to get back to those top three
issues very
quickly probably stat to striven um Matt
thank you very much indeed uh everyone
should read your new book uh values
voice and virtue uh and please come on
spectator TV again soon as just
mentioned the government has banned
smoking for young people it will be a
phased ban but it's a ban nonetheless uh
but a very interesting article on
spectator life this week asked the
question is social media worse for
teenagers than smoking uh Cara Asher
Smith who is the director of the center
for social justice uh wrote that piece
uh she joins us now along with Mary
Wakefield our commissioning editor uh
Cara I'll start with you um you think
that the government should be as serious
about banning social media as it is
about stopping smoking yes I do um I
think that parents are currently between
a rock and a hard place so if you don't
give your child a smartphone with access
to social media um you're risking you
know when they're older you're risking
them getting bullied you're risking
serious social isolation and you know
inability to form friendships which
they're all doing through their phones
so a parents wearing up that with saying
okay but then there's also the mental
health issues that they could get from
giving them the smartphone um which is
why I think the government needs to step
in here and um I think we need two
things I think we need a legislative
change um brought about where which
basically doesn't allow um anybody under
16 to have access to social media and
I'm sure greater minds than mine would
be able to work out the best best way to
do that um but I also think we need to
have a shift in the whole culture of
this country so that it becomes you know
shocking to see a young child with a
smartphone or a young teenager um you
know as said in the article there
shocking as seeing a
10-year-old making a Ry or drinking a
bottle of vodka yes you point in your
piece towards this is it sapian Labs yes
sapian lab study that you told me just
before we started recording came out in
May yeah uh
that suggested that the impact on young
girls is much worse than on young boys
why do you think that is it is I think
that girls are really lacking in
confidence at um in their young teenage
years they're more concerned with what
they look like broadly than guys and I
think they can feel for whatever reasons
more socially insecure um and I think
the way that the videos the videos on
Tik Tok videos on Instagram are set up
they are just bringing out the worst
aspect of teenage girls you know they
really are focused on the most
superficial side um of of of girls it's
all about dancing and diet tips and
makeup there's no videos that I saw um
which were about what books these
children are into or what issues Inspire
them it was yes um and you think Tik Tok
and Snapchat and all the apps are are
most popular with the young people are
the are the worst ones yes exactly and
there's a particularly awful feature on
Snapchat which um my god daughter told
me about which is where you connect with
somebody and then um they all are
tracking each other's live live
locations so my god daughter was sitting
on the sofa with us as a family and she
saw all her friends going off to a party
in North that she hadn't been invited to
then she sees all her friends going over
to someone else's house I mean it's just
designed to send young I know I know a
few young people who follow their exes
obsessively so you never have an ex
anymore if you're on Snapchat M because
um if they've ditched you you're very
invested in finding out where they are
what they're doing and they just through
the night they don't sleep they're
following these exes ex-girlfriends
ex-boyfriends to see where they're going
whose houses they're going into hell
isn't it very you and I have talked
about the point that we are both
tremendous Hypocrites as parents we are
but that's the point of being a parent
an opportunity to be I need to establish
for for the viewers why we're Hypocrites
because we are horrendously addicted to
our I think you're a little worse than I
am I think I think you may be right yeah
uh but of course it's very hard for us
to then set an example to our children
because they see us on our phones all
the time and they associate that with
being grown up they think it's a
grown-up thing to do is to stare at the
screen all day yeah do you have that
thing where you suddenly catch a a
glimpse of what you must look like as a
family on a Saturday after or something
and then everyone's on a different
device and you feel you know sad but
then you don't stop it so yeah know we
are addicts and it's very hard for kids
to I'm definitely an addict yeah I'm an
addict who is who but we also know
Freddy We also discussed how Terri it's
terrible for our brains you know you
find yourself just scrolling sideways
all the time and not developing
consecutive thoughts as easily not
reading novels so we know how bad it is
for our kids uh and it must be worse for
more impressionable more plastic brain
are pretty much dead so of course you
Mary you have some doubts I think about
it being particularly worse for girls
than it is for boys you I just don't
know I mean you know I think sort of
statistically or psychologically women
um react to sort of stress differently
so female prisoners will self harm and
male prisoners will punish someone else
we've looked at what we've asked kids is
um how anxious and depressed are you and
the girls have said very like 70% of Jen
Zed are anxious or something and as a
result of smartphone use we think but
maybe we're not asking the boys the
right question I just don't think anyone
studied the effect it's having on boys
which may be different that's my only
point there I mean I think I'm sure
that's true as well I think that boys
are just on social media a bit less yeah
right then yeah I think so than the
girls and I mean I think for boys
there's obviously gaming is a massive
issue as boys get older is that a
problem gaming well I mean so
anecdotally purely anecdotally i' I've
seen that as a yes a big problem um and
um you know I think boys really do get
swept up into this um cyber world yeah
um and can get very addicted to it and
then of course there's also pornography
which is an issue that is affecting boys
but um
the government is doing something about
pornography and bullying or was trying
to through the online arms Bill uh but
what you're saying is the government
should be more uh dragonian about it it
should say uh no social media accounts
for anyone the age of 16 yes because I
think that what the politicians are
doing they're focusing on um smartphones
and schools which is quite right and I
thought the announcement by Jillian
Keegan was brilliant um but what there
and then in the online online harm spill
they're focusing on you know viewing
harmful content but what they're not
doing as far as I can see is talking
about the mental health issues from
social media it's just my Miriam Kate's
talks about it but beyond that it
doesn't seem to be much of a Cora why is
it government's job I mean I I you know
was lucky enough to talk to Dr Jean twen
who's the author of generations bit of a
plug for her there um and she is
extremely impressive very grown up I
don't think uses her smartphone too much
and she said she has just told her
teenage daughters they don't have one
and I said are they okay with that and
she said she looked quite Fierce and
said yes absolutely they're fine they've
got text so they arranged to meet up
with their friends but they don't have
any of the apps they have what you know
the the the sort of dumb phones as it
were why isn't it a parents job
shouldn't we all be more Jee twinge and
just say no kids so I have a lot I have
a lot of sympathy to the Nan State
argument but I think when it comes to
children children it's this point that
the children don't really stand a chance
and I think parents find it so
overwhelming back to this dichotomy of
they've got you know there's so much
against them if they don't have a phone
but they could have the phone with just
the texts on it yes and they're not
going to be able to pay for it
themselves so you really do have quite a
lot of control here you can say I'm
sorry darling you know blame me well I
think there a lot of good parents would
try to do that a lot of good parents
would fail to do that I think but then
there are a lot of who just simply won't
bother to do that so I suppose car's
your argument is that the there is
there's no stopping children having
smart unless you and access social media
accounts unless you do it at the yes the
government just says your kids are not
allowed smartphones well I think they be
allowed I think they have smartphones
but not have access to social media I
don't know maybe they do it through like
some proper age verification process or
something like that but I think the
point is that these apps are addictive
and I kind of think in the same way we
don't allow access you know to Children
of addictive drugs with protecting
children I think they should be
protected from The Addictive nature of
these apps which have been designed by
you know the best Harvard PhD mines um
in the M of funding the billions that's
gone into the funding on this um I think
our our children need to a bit of
protection from it at lastly you're both
mothers what are your policies with your
own children uh I'll start with you cara
um well at the moment they they don't
have smartphones at all but I think I'm
sure by the time they're 40 and I I'll
probably cave because I think the social
pressure on them is huge and I would
worry about them getting bullied but I'd
love to think I would be a bit stronger
than that m is to look at my phone and
keep the kid at arms length and say
don't talk to me I'm on my phone that's
why but K is is he's only seven he's
seven um yeah I I think I'm not going to
let him have one but you'll have to um
get back to me on that my eldest is 12
and we've held out so far but we shall
see good luck Freddy uh the pressure is
definitely coming yeah uh Cara and Mary
thank you very much for coming on
spectator
TV that's it for this week a rather
somber show uh for obvious reasons uh
but I hope you found it useful and
informative um I should also before we
go thank our brilliant sponsors canor
genuity wealth management once more
visit can do wealth.com to find out more
information about them and do tune in
again next week
[Music]